hey everyone so in the last couple
videos i was talking about various
functions of money and people usually
list at least three different functions
that it serves the first is a medium of
exchange it's what we use to trade for
goods the second is that it's a store of
value if you keep your money around
it'll retain its value and the third is
that it's a unit of value we usually
think of things in you know dollar terms
or euro or peso or yen terms and some
texts will actually add a fourth
function of money onto this which is
that money is the standard of deferred
payment
standard
of
deferred payment
now what does this mean what does
deferred payment mean basically it's any
time that you receive something but only
pay for it later and the most common
form of this is debt so let's say that
you you're over here and you want to
borrow a thousand dollars so you borrow
one thousand dollars maybe it's from
some kind of institution like a bank
and maybe it's a let's say it's a
thousand dollar credit card loan uh so
you receive it and then some kind of
time passes maybe it's like the month
before your credit card bill comes some
time passes and then after that you
repay that debt
and you'll repay it with money um and
this is probably the most common where
you're receiving you know money to use
for something and then you pay it back
but there are other forms of deferred
payment like if you go to a restaurant
for example where you receive your food
before you pay your bill at the end that
would actually be a form of a deferred
payment because you know you receive
your food at the start of the evening
and then you eat it and it's only at the
end that you pay it hopefully your bill
isn't a thousand dollars but it is
something where you're paying it at the
end and insofar as money is what we use
to repay this
this is its fourth function
and now you might be able to see why
some people think that this shouldn't
count as an extra one because you could
argue that this falls under the category
of a medium of exchange you know just in
the same way that you use money to buy a
chair or to buy legal services or to buy
food
you're using money to pay your debt it's
just another one of those things that
you're exchanging for so why should this
be separated well one case that you
could make for why this idea of a
standard of deferred payment really does
serve a different function than the
others is that at least in modern
economies there's somewhat of a legal
backing to the idea of money serving
this standard and by that i mean if you
take on a debt in a country and there's
some kind of legal obligation attached
to that debt associated with the legal
system of the country tied into the law
is the idea that you can pay back that
debt with money and if you've ever heard
the term legal tender
legal tender
this is what it's referring to so legal
tender you might have heard of like
dollar bills or coins and things like
that being called legal tender and what
this means so legal indicates that
there's some association with the system
of law within a given country and tender
tender is kind of an old word for offer
and what this basically means is that if
you take on a debt like you know you
borrow a thousand dollars from the bank
or you you know eat food in a restaurant
before you pay for it as soon as you
offer money as soon as you offer
something which is legal tender so like
dollar bills that debt will no longer
exist the act of offering it alone will
eliminate that debt and just as an
example of why this has some bearing
consider the fact that it used to be the
case people would often take out loans
in gold like in the late 1800s for
example when a lot of railroads were
being built and there was debt being
raised to support the building of those
it would often be the case that one of
the men building these railroads might
borrow a large sum of money but he would
borrow it in the form of a lot of gold
some kind of gold and then it was
expected that he could pay this back you
know in that same form he could pay back
the gold itself
you know maybe plus interest this is why
people would give him gold in the first
place and it might be you know maybe
it's just a lot of um
people looking to invest the gold that
they're holding and hoping that it
returns some kind of interest
now let's think about what would happen
if you tried to do this today where if
instead of you know back in the back in
the era you were doing this
today
so let's say you borrowed like one ounce
of gold so it might be one
ounce of gold and say that corresponded
today to one thousand dollars if it was
one thousand dollars for every ounce of
gold then let's say while you're holding
on to it you know some time passes
you're investing it maybe instead of
building railroads you're doing
something more modern with it but let's
say after enough time has passed the
gold has actually gone up in value you
know maybe there's been inflation or
maybe for whatever reason the gold is
now a higher price and instead instead
let's say after the time it's now two
thousand dollars
two thousand dollars for a single ounce
of gold
now if you were to pay back exactly what
you received you would pay back one
ounce of gold maybe plus some interest
and nobody would have any reason to
complain however legally you're allowed
to pay back your debt in the form of the
legal tender of the country so for
example in the united states since your
original loan was in the form of a
thousand dollars you could pay back
instead of in gold one thousand dollars
just us dollars and just by offering
that to the people who originally gave
you the loan the debt would be gone but
in effect what this would mean is that
you're paying back half an ounce of gold
because after this time has passed you
know the dollar has devalued relative to
gold and instead a thousand dollars
would only buy half an ounce of gold and
you might imagine people would be kind
of unhappy about that
so the whole point here is that the
standard of deferred payment actually
has some legal clout to it so what could
what you could argue separates it from
the other functions of money is this
fact that the currency in most modern
economies is actually tied up with the
legal system of the associated country
so with that i will see you next video